chat GPT goes around the world and now
is finally available as an API AI can
now read your brain and meta's llamas
weights leak in a hilarious fashion
welcome to ml news I'm your host Janik
and nice that you're here
[Music]
to ml news first things first it's GTC
time nvidia's GTC conference is
happening in March 20 to 23rd especially
the keynote is happening on March 21st
so you should not miss this not only
because it's a very cool conference it's
completely free you can attend all the
sessions that you want but also because
if you do you can win a graphics card so
you can win a really nice 4090 TI signed
by Jensen Huang this is exclusive to
only very few places and I'm very happy
that my channel is one of them so go to
ykilcher.com GTC if you want to
participate note that you do have to be
in Emir in order to do so if you're not
you can still go to this website and
I'll raffle out some merch and to make
this even more fleshy I have interviewed
the VP of Applied deep learning research
at Nvidia Brian katanzaro and I'll post
the interview with him at the end of
this video this is important because
this person in large part decides what
the future of Hardware is going to be
Nvidia does research themselves in order
to estimate the trends going forward and
in order to adjust their Hardwares their
software and so on to what they think
will be the future and Brian is at the
dead center of that thing so whatever
Brian does and thinks and says and
creates is probably gonna have a very
large impact on how the Deep learning
field evolves in the near future so
definitely worth a listen as I said the
interviewers at the end of this video
and now let's dive into the news direct
Brockman tweets chat GPT API is now
available so the chat GPT model that has
been only available as a web interface
as a research preview is now available
in the open AI API which means you can
give them money in order to interact
with chat GPT in a programmatic way it's
a lot cheaper than the DaVinci models
the classic GPT 3 models which we might
infer it's probably a bit smaller than
them but who knows maybe they've just
gotten more more efficient or they've
determined that this pricing is better
in any case it's about 10 percent the
price of the large models and not only
is the chat GPT model available but
they've also activated the whisper model
in their API now whisper is a model that
they have previously given out open
source it is a model that takes in
speech and transcribes that speech and
it does so very well so now also that is
available in their API so it becomes
easier and easier as a developer to
interact with AI to interact with these
models you don't have to know deep
learning or Frameworks anymore I for one
think it's a cool direction that a lot
more of these apis are offered I
obviously also think that open AI with
their big speech about democratizing and
sharing and so on is you know what they
say and what they do is 180 degrees
apart from each other but in principle I
think it's a good direction for
developers that these things are
generally available as apis on their
blog they have a few examples for
example a Quizlet here is using it to
automatically create like quizzes about
things that you might want to learn so
this is essentially a personalized tutor
that's done via chat GPT so I believe
that there's a lot of interesting
applications and certainly other people
have believed that as well because we're
now seeing like a ginormous flood of
applications of everyone hooking into
the chat GPT API and just saying how
easy this is uh Greg Boggs on Twitter
has tweeted out build the command line
chatbot in Python with the chat GPT API
16 lines of code I'm not sure anyone's
ever shipped a more powerful Dev tool
than open AI he's also released a blog
post of how exactly does that and it's
deceptively simple all you do is you
define this system parameter and the
system essentially says you know you are
a helpful assistant or like please
pretend to be someone from the Moon
something like this then you take turns
in you know providing messages the model
is called GPT 3.5 turbo again we're not
sure if it's a smaller version of gpt3
if it's like just a faster version for
Hardware reasons nobody knows but with a
few API calls with a few web calls you
can definitely just you know make a
chatbot or make it do pretty much
anything so the blog post goes a bit
over the changes that you have to make
if you previously use the old openai
models and now I want to switch to chat
GPT I'll leave a link in the description
also open AI is moving more and more
towards sort of the business world the
way from the research World they have
new policies so Sam Altman tweeted data
submitted to the open AI API is not used
for training and we have a new 30-day
retention policy and are open to Less on
a case-by-case basis we've also removed
our pre-launch review and made our terms
of service and usage policies more
developer friendly so everything for
open AI goes into the direction of
essentially providing AI as a service
and much less you know taking part in
research that is also evidenced by a
leak that happened a few days earlier
which is called the open AI Foundry
which is essentially a system at least
as the screenshots here claim where open
AI essentially provides dedicated
Hardware dedicated inference Hardware to
businesses so you can go to opener and
you can give them some money for example
here if you want to do a one-year commit
to The DaVinci model with 32 000 token
context you just give them one and a
half million easy peasy and then you get
a one year dedicated 600 units instances
whatever that is you get dedicated
hardware for you so no one else you know
can interfere with you this is likely
targeting businesses probably larger
businesses that have significant demands
and constant demands for these types of
workloads and lastly there is now a
collaboration between open Ai and Bain
and Company which is like a Consulting
shop like a marketing Consulting shop
and open AI brings their technology in
order to make payment companies business
better so you might know them for
example from Coca-Cola they say with
chat GPT and Ali we're helping Coca-Cola
to augment its world-class Brands
marketing and consumer experiences in
Industry leading ways we're also using
openai technology to improve business
operations and capabilities now that it
doesn't say anything but they are very
much talking about like very Target ads
for example so by using Dali or
something like this and chat GPT you can
make very targeted ads to individual
users now is every single one of these
ads gonna come with a big fat disclaimer
that that was done by an AI no no who
would have guessed I'm sure Stanford is
like shaking shaking in their boats
writing lectures left and right
yeah I mean it's a company so that's
fine I'm not wanna don't wanna complain
about this however at the same time from
the ground floor of the trading Corners
they're now getting back on their horse
and here we are with a blog post
planning for AGI and Beyond I want to
say it's a bit of a like a Fluff piece
that just repeats again and again how
much they want to benefit all of
humanity and it's essentially a
justification for them not being what
they set out to be at the beginning at
least part of it is so they for example
speak about how at the beginning they
were you know not expecting that scaling
was so important for example this side
note here we didn't expect scaling to be
as important as it turned out to be when
we realized it was going to be critical
we also realized our original structure
wasn't going to work we simply wouldn't
be able to raise enough money to
accomplish our mission as a non-profit
and we came up with a new structure they
also said as another example we now
believe we were wrong in our original
thinking about openness and pivoted from
thinking we should release everything to
thinking that we should figure out how
to safely share access and benefits of
the system we still believe the benefits
of what is happening are huge and the
yada yada yada essentially as I said
it's a justification for the fact that
they're not open anymore not non-profit
anymore they're very much making money
which again is fine for a company but
don't at the same time talk to me about
openness and sharing and so on this is
very much we're going to develop this
we're going to make money off of it and
we tell you what's good for you they
claim to be still open in other ways yet
they don't no one knows how you know
what exactly is running when you do a
gpt3 inference or a chat GPT inference
no one knows how the supposed good
safety filters of that thing work no one
knows you know what training data
exactly went into these models none of
these things are known and none of these
things will probably ever be known to in
in detail so it's very much the opposite
of open and it's very much not sharing
it with everyone and maximizing the
benefit of humanity they're couching
this in a language of like safety and
ooh the substantial risks of AGI this is
a Silicon Valley company right so I'm
totally ready to believe that someone is
delusional enough to think that they are
on the doorsteps of AGI and and that the
risk is so big and they just have to do
something on the other hand isn't it
just like very convenient that that's
also like the way that your company
makes the most money and that your
company can retain as much stuff as
possible even though you set out to do
the exact opposite it just seems like a
lot of convenience coming together
that's all I'm saying again given that
it's a Silicon Valley company it's
totally possible that people actually
believe that in any case you may read
this there's not too much information in
there but yeah that's that
now with the success of chat gbt the
influencers come and I know I know I'm I
know glass houses blah blah blah but
certainly everyone is giving tips left
and right of how jat GPT works and you
know what to do oh you can earn 300 000
by prompt engineering oh this odd jet
GPT skill pays 335
000 a year create a course online using
100 AI like you know you just type into
chat GPT make me a course and then you
make a course why wouldn't someone just
go to chat GPT themselves if you just
make the course using chat GPT chat GPT
is supreme but it has limitations here
are 10 must-know AI tools to work
smarter not harder in 2023 it's like
it's always like you just you just
change the words of these influencer
people and then they always wanna they
always have a sub stack or something
where you subscribe by the way I have a
patron I have a patreon just you know
just saying like look oh this pen this
pen you thought you knew how a pen
worked but no you've been using pens
wrong all all your life here are 10
websites 10 awesome tools to use your
pen better in 2023 follow my sub stack
chat GPT and Bard are phenomenal AI but
these 50 new websites to finish hours of
work in minutes I'm giving away a few
Premium Accounts go go a threat oh a
threat wow that's something new never
seen that on Twitter the awesome chat
GPT prompts repo is now available 50
awesome chat GPT prom ah influencers now
of course like all of this is probably
like useful information to someone so I
don't want to dump on this but there's
is definitely an industry of sort of
making clout off of the hype now and
again glass houses yeah but I'm pretty
sure I was here before chat GPT existed
in any case I actually welcome the
additional attention I feel it's cool
that the world kind of is taking notice
of what's going on right here except the
European Union the European Union is
welcome to just not not look enough
listen because it will just try to
regulate everything that's not fun but
everyone else welcome welcome to the
field
[Music]
there's definitely also good content for
example uh this here is a free and open
source course on prompting communicating
with artificial intelligence you can
just go there you don't have to
subscribe to a sub stack it's free in
open source if you want to get into
prompting this might be a resource
learnprompting.org Google researchers
release a new model A ul2 has been
released a few weeks ago but oh okay
ul2 has been released a few weeks ago or
months even it's a 20 billion parameter
model that has a very new interesting
training Paradigm and now they've taken
that and tuned it in a planned way so
flan is a code name for models that have
been instruction tuned in various
Fashions there's always been plan T5
beforehand and flan other models and now
there is flan ul2 so the checkpoints
here are available on hogging face you
may go you may download them you may try
them and maybe they'll help you
especially if you have some sort of
instruction following task doing things
so an example is this query right here
answer the following question by
reasoning step by step the cafeteria 23
Apostles so if you have some sort of
task and you want a response questions
you want a response maybe this model is
good to check out
speaking of model checkpoints the Llama
weights have been leaked well llama
you'd have to go through this process of
a forum to apply to meta and they
determine whether your heart is pure
enough to really wield the Llama weights
they were only for research now they've
been leaked and the fun thing is some a
person has submitted a pull request to
the the Llama code base and the pull
request the change here so there's a
link to the Google form the pull request
changes that by two or if you want to
save your bandwidth use this torrent
linked there is a magnet link or
BitTorrent first people said well this
is one of the meta researchers who
mistakenly sort of put that there and
shouldn't have you should only give that
to people actually filled out the form
before yet it's as far as I can tell
this person who made the pull request
that Christopher King 42 is an automata
researcher or a mistaken even if they
are do not trust this pie torch model
files contain executable code only trust
this once we have verifiable checksums
of these files I'm totally ready to
believe that these are the correct
weights they their size matches and so
on but is very dangerous you just
download them from somewhere what's
funny is the response of the community
so this is the the request and the bot
like the GitHub bot is guiding them
through the process like hey thank you
for your podcast Welcome to our
community and so they they ask him to to
sign the license agreement and then
people just jumped in and approved the
changes on GitHub you can just go and
review a pull request so people jump in
going looks good to me and so apparently
uh Kristoff signed the license we can
now accept your code thanks so the
comment section is going nuts and on the
right hand side you see the reviewers
with all kinds of approvals and you know
in general people are very happy about
this change I love the internet the
internet is great by the way open
assistant is going apps absolutely
fantastic the data we've collected so
far is phenomenal and we are continuing
we're also training the first models
we're all preparing to do V1 releases
yeah that's that's going well if you
don't know about this project yet go to
open dash assistant dot IO grab a task
play the assistant and um help us all
right there's a new paper by researchers
from Japan that's been accepted at cvpr
and it's literally reading your mind
like literally so on the top you can see
presented images to people like actual
people and then from an fmri scan this
system can reconstruct these things at
the bottom so you'll see that they do
match in sort of a little bit visually
but also like semantically a lot so a
snowboarder in the snow a tower with a
clock on it so on and it's relatively
simple so they have a training data set
of people where they present images and
measure their brain activity and what
what they do is they simply train sort
of encoders and and decoders here from
brain space to latent space of the
stable diffusion model so they don't
train a big model to reconstruct these
images they just take stable diffusion
and they assume that all the information
you need to reconstruct images is
already there and they just need to
train a little mapping from brain
activity to the latent space of stable
diffusion and that works pretty well and
as you can see you know right here it's
quite fantastic they have some
hypotheses of which brain areas map to
which parts for example the the latent
Vector Z right here or the conditioning
Vector C how why are they called so so
similarly see the conditioning Vector is
usually that's the text Vector in stable
diffusion so you take the different
brain area signals you learn a mapping
from those to the latent vectors in the
stable diffusion process and then you
just let it run yeah it's it's pretty
amazing how far we're coming not only is
it a amazing that we can sort of read
people's thoughts but it also I think
tells a lot about like our models that
we have might be not as far off as
brains in terms of how they understand
images and their contents right so for
example here you can see sky and down
here you can see sky and one is sort of
more or less cloudy the other one is
more bluish and so on it's sort of but
semantically it kind of matches and
that's what's fascinating to me so it's
not just that the colors are right you
know the pixels are somehow it's kind of
matching semantically that leads me to
believe that we're sort of getting
closer at understanding ourselves by
training these models and that's by the
way also why I have quite a bit of Hope
for sort of the large language models
people always argue who the large
language models aren't intelligent they
don't understand anything and so on and
in my mind it's not a question of sort
of what the large language models can't
do but the question is much more are you
as a human doing really that much more
than sort of statistically interpolating
your training data like are you really
doing that much more I have my doubts
that you are like that far ahead of
something that just kind of does
statistical you know look-alike
inference of the training data I think
humans overestimate themselves a little
bit in how smart they are and here's
another paper about brain mind reading
evidence of a predictive coding
hierarchy in the human brain listening
to speech so again we're dealing with
fmri images as I think so yes or at
least brain readings yes fmri images and
this time it's not people watching
images it's people listening to speech
at the same time they take the same
speech and feed it into language models
and they see sort of how far ahead the
human brain must be predicting in order
to really listen and understand that
speech and then they compare them to the
language model and they find a lot of
evidence for what they call a predictive
coding hierarchy which means that they
the human brain very probably predicts
not just at one time scale like our
language models currently do but at
multiple time scales so different
regions in the brain do predict the text
at a different sort of frames and
different granularities and also
hierarchically which means that they
first sort of predict what the general
thing is that's coming up and then they
predict sort of the different elements
and only at the end they predict the
individual tokens from this hierarchical
information a lot of evidence is being
generated again I think by training
these models we come closer and closer
to understanding ourselves and that's
pretty cool
[Music]
foreign now understanding ourselves uh
is good and well but the robots aren't
so well alphabet lays off hit trash
sorting robots right wired so this is
Everyday Robots it's a section beneath
alphabet that was doing these kinds of
robots that could do household tasks
they could go around they have cameras
you could teach them stuff they could as
you can see here clean a table and so on
now this problem it looks easy but it is
really really really hard for robots in
the real world you know one of these
chairs could be a bit different the
tables could be a bit different there
could be something in the way and so on
the robotics in the real world is really
hard and Everyday Robots has now been
hit by the big Tech layoff wave that's
currently sweeping these large companies
so Denise Gamboa director of marketing
and Communications forever the robot
says Everyday Robots will no longer be a
separate project within alphabet some of
the technology and part of the team will
be Consolidated into existing robotics
efforts within Google research so it's
partly of part restructuring but yeah I
think it just shows robotics is quite
hard and maybe not as fruitful right now
but who knows what the future brings
maybe just not as profitable this is an
article on the hugging face blog it's a
swift diffuser so this is stable
diffusion on Mac so if you have like an
M1 chip you can get or an M2 Chip you
can get very fast stable diffusion by
simply downloading this app from the App
Store very cool pyribs is a library for
Quality diversity optimization quality
diversity is a technique in sort of the
Forever Learning space in the space of
hey let's train things without having
objective functions or without having
the single objective function and this
often leads to more robust results more
diverse results and so on and this is a
library that supports that so if you're
in the space of lifelong learning
exploratory learning evolutionary search
things like this maybe check out this
Library Ron Chung tweets the most
disturbing AI website on the internet
upload a photo of a person and AI will
find all of the image images of that
person across the internet this is about
a website called Pim eyes and you upload
a photo and it uses facial recognition
and it searches your your face I don't
know is it is it good or bad that this
exists and is accessible who knows like
you can do Google image search right you
can do image reverse search you can find
a particular picture you can classify
pictures in in Google image search you
can certainly search the internet for
your exact name right in Google you just
quotes and you put your name you can
find yourself so why is it that tragic
if you can find an image of yourself
that I don't know on the other hand it
does seem quite creepy of course it is
possible to do this because it's
possible it's pretty sure that all the
governments are already doing it so then
you can also ask yourself is it that bad
that like a private company is doing it
so they offer you things like you can
have alerts if a picture of you appears
somewhere you can also erase your
picture so this is very much like other
pii Erasure websites they would go to
external websites and kind of bully them
to get rid of your picture well bully
them they would use legal means in order
for them to get rid of your picture and
so on I'm not sure what to think of this
website I'm not per se against it this
one here there's an opt out request so
you can opt out but I tend to de-proof
is required means you you have to submit
your passport if you want to opt out of
this that seems a bit Shady like that
that seems I'm not sure how else you
would do it but it does seem a bit Shady
that in order if I'm concerned about my
privacy I have to send my passport to
some company for them not to allow
others to invade my privacy that's a bit
fishy that's all I'm saying alright the
last helpful thing cacti is a framework
for scalable multitask multi-scene
visual imitation learning this is a
multi-step process and the framework
helps you in achieving all of the steps
so collect data this is demonstrations
for kind of robots and Robotics then
augment your data compress that data and
at the end train an agent on that data
so here's a bit of a video of robots
doing cool things I I do think you know
I said before robotics is really hard
I'm very happy that other companies
aren't stopping their robotics efforts
Google isn't either but I feel like
robots are still a lot cooler than
really smart chat Bots I know I know a
really smart chat bot might change a lot
more lives than a single robot I just
think robots are cooler and I'm very
happy research is happening into that
direction shout out to sanyam bhutani
who has used control net and the pytorch
logo to do really awesome images and
these are really really cool and it does
show how easy it is nowadays just to do
air just to be creative with these tools
I'm planning to do a bit of a dedicated
video on just tools that exist but the
landscape changes so much you wait a
week week and there are three new major
tools out like this one control net it's
just it's like blows your mind what it
can do where previously you'd have to
have extremely serious Photoshop skills
in order to achieve this yeah shout out
these look amazing all right we're at
the point where we go over to the
interview with Brian Catanzaro again
this is the VP of Applied deep learning
research at Nvidia and he's going to
tell us a little bit about what Nvidia
is doing in research what the plans for
the future are what their mission is and
what you can expect from his talk at GTC
again go to whykilter.com GTC in order
to take part in the raffle and maybe win
an awesome GPU and have a lot of fun
attending GTC I hope to see you there
and bye bye
my my name is Brian katanzaro it's an
Italian name pronounced it very like
latinate you know yeah so I I wanna I
wanted to ask you a little bit about
Nvidia and Nvidia research specifically
because I always think of Nvidia as you
know the graphics card manufacturer so
I'm a question that I really had all my
life essentially for I've known Nvidia
is why doesn't Nvidia even do research
why do we see cool papers coming out of
Nvidia and I remember the first big one
was like really scaling up Gans and
making really beautiful images out of
that why does why do you even do that
why don't you just sell more cards and
have others do it well Nvidia is not
about selling cards and videos and
accelerated Computing company which
means that we're trying to build
technology that allows people to solve
problems that just could not be solved
any other way and we know that in order
to do that we have to optimize every
part of the technology that includes the
chips but also it includes the working
it includes the systems the chips go
into it includes all the software the
Frameworks the compilers the libraries
the applications the algorithms all of
these things are connected and they have
to be optimized jointly in order to get
the benefits of accelerated Computing
you know our business is not just to
sell a chip what we're trying to do is
enable people to solve problems they
couldn't do without without accelerated
Computing and and so that means we have
to understand the applications deeply
and and that means we need to do
research one of the things that's
challenging about being in the
accelerated Computing business is that
we have to be extraordinarily focused on
what we think the most important
computational problems of the future are
as we're creating this technology
um you know accelerated Computing
implies decelerated Computing we're
going to focus on the few things that we
think are the very most important
computational problems and we're going
to push the limits every part of the
computation every part of the
infrastructure is going to be optimized
in order to solve that problem
and then the other stuff we're going to
let go we're not going to worry about
that we're going to let you know
traditional systems non-accelerated
systems take care of that so the
fundamental question of accelerated
Computing is what are you going to
accelerate
um and so research helps figure that out
and you know I was able to be involved
in that uh when I joined Nvidia research
in 2008 uh so 15 years ago I was the
only person working on artificial
intelligence and um you know I had the
freedom to investigate what would it
mean for artificial intelligence to run
on the GPU how could we make libraries
for that how could we accelerate AI on
the GPU and you know being involved in
that project I think has been really
good for me I've I've had a lot of fun
and I think obviously Nvidia has been
able to focus so much on AI but it you
know as many things happen at Nvidia it
starts with an exploration it starts
starts with a question it starts with
research and so Nvidia research has been
instrumental in a lot of different
technologies that have been important to
Nvidia Ray tracing artificial
intelligence the the generative AI that
that you brought up our work in Gans you
know all of this comes from our desire
to better understand the most important
computational work and then figure out
how we can push that forward
is that would you say that's your your
mission statement or do you have sort of
an overarching demand from the company
like here is the one thing you should be
doing or is it that is it what you say
is it push the Frontiers so we know
what's coming tomorrow
sometimes we talk about the mission of
research being to lift the headlights of
the company so that the company can see
just a little bit farther into the
future I think also research provides a
place to incubate ideas that we think
are promising but aren't proven yet
um we know as a company that the only
constant is change if you look at the
kinds of workloads we've been
accelerating over the years
um there's been a ton of change you know
we know that the workloads of the future
can't be the same as the workloads of
the past because the applications of the
future are different and we also know
that the value of accelerated Computing
is enabling people to solve new problems
it can't be just about retreading the
problems of the past if we just built
systems let's say for example that we're
the fastest in the world at training
resnet 50. we just focused every bit of
our might for Accelerated Computing on
resnet50 then we would have missed
generative AI right because resnet 50
isn't generative AI it's a
discriminative problem you're just
trying to classify an image and so um we
know that the applications of the future
are different from the applications of
the past we know that the choices about
what applications are important are
critical to nvidia's future because
again if we're trying to build
accelerated Computing we have to know
what to accelerate and what to not
accelerate and
um you know research is part of the way
that Nvidia decides how to answer these
questions for itself it's not the only
way I mean there's people all over the
company that are incredibly Innovative
and building awesome technology and have
deep understandings of of AI and where
the future is going it's it's not
research's job to be sort of the only
people thinking about the future the
whole company is thinking about the
future but research has I think a
special ability to incubate things and
to ask questions that that maybe the
company hasn't been asking yet so this
question might seem a little bit cheesy
but uh Jensen Huang said that Nvidia
chooses to solve the hardest problem not
not the easy convenient ones which plays
a little bit into the the role of what
you're saying right now there is a way
in which you know leaders just say that
because it sounds cool
um but what do you what do you
understand like how do you
how do you go about that right if I
assume you take it seriously to solve
the hardest problems what can you give
us an example of that
well I think one of the ways this
manifests has to do with um creating
something new
um I think Nvidia is generally oriented
to build something new rather than to
um
enter into some battle some zero-sum
battle where somebody's gonna win and
somebody's gonna lose we love starting
in a market that no one cares about yet
but that we have a lot of conviction in
um and that's always going to be hard
you know it takes enormous conviction to
go into a market that's worth zero
billion dollars in plant you know all of
your energy and all of your focus on
that market because you you believe that
in the future that that's going to
matter and you know generally it's it's
the case that uh if you're working in a
in a space like that that there's a ton
of problems everywhere you know if the
problems were well understood if they
had already been solved then there would
already be tons of people working in
that space and so when Jensen says we
focus on the hard problems I think he's
right I think that is our culture at
Nvidia and I think the reason that we do
that is because we believe that's where
the most interesting problems are and we
believe it's where we can add the most
value can you maybe give you know I
guess what we're talking about the
future and recognizing future markets
recognizing what devices we need to
build for the future
can you give us a little bit of insight
don't don't reveal any company Secrets
but you know we had stable diffusion
come along we had chat GPT come along
and what do you see if I just could
guess what the future is it's bigger
Transformers that's kind of it's kind of
boring so I'm wondering you know where
do you see the the future the next few
years it's such an interesting question
I mean first of all I have to say bigger
Transformers are not boring to me
um one of the reasons is that they just
keep doing more and more amazing things
when the Transformer first came out you
know in 2017 and it you had that famous
title attention is all you need it was
kind of perceived as a joke right but
nowadays it doesn't feel quite so much
like a joke it's amazing it's
extraordinary you know the The Bert
models of 2018 were incredible language
models for the day and yet the
difference between a Bert model and a
chat GPT model over the past five years
is extraordinary and the understanding
of
um intelligence in their ability to do
problem solving
um you know I think uh the the thing
that's so extraordinary right now about
um the large language models that that
we're seeing is that they actually are
able to solve problems that they've
never been trained to do we call that
zero shot reasoning and that's
extraordinarily valuable because it
allows us to apply them to all sorts of
new places and so I think that um uh you
know just as larger Transformers you
could say the only difference between
Bert and Chachi PT is that Chachi PT is
trained on a lot more data with a little
bit different training objective but
it's still just a much bigger
Transformer
um I think in between Chachi PT and what
we're going to see in the future five
years from now is also going to be
extraordinary change
um you know I I personally am going to
bet that huge Transformers are still
going to stay part of that change
because they just have proven themselves
to be so flexible and useful
um but I but I don't think that's not
exciting I mean I I'm totally excited
about it
um so I think there's going to be a
proliferation of applications of this
technology uh in new ways
um obviously there's a lot of problems
with
um Chachi PT we love Chachi PT it's so
exciting it's caught the industry's
imagination it's caught the Public's
imagination and yet we know that
it needs to be better at factual
question answering it needs to be better
at uh using current information you know
perhaps including tools like web search
um or you know the ability to write code
um in order to solve problems I think
that uh what we're going to see is a
composition of these language models
that really expand our capabilities to
problem solve before I before I forget
and our time runs out do you want to
give us a little bit of a preview of
your session at GTC why here's your
chance to tell people why they should
come and and watch yeah well this year
at GTC I'm giving a talk about
generative Ai and sort of explaining
what it is where it comes from and where
we think it's going
um obviously generative AI is having a
big moment
um Mark Zuckerberg just announced that
Facebook's building a new top level
product group focused on generative AI
Microsoft has pivoted so much of their
strategy to incorporate generative of AI
in in bing and other products and I
think that
um you know we're seeing uh this
incredible interest in general AI
Technologies across the industry
um so the question is you know how
should we understand that what is this
technology how is it built
um you know what are its strengths what
are its current limitations where do we
think it's going and
um what is it what does it mean for us
and for the technology industry and so
that's what I'm going to be talking
about you just um you said you you
believe Transformers will be part will
sort of stay with us maybe a little bit
they will be able to do more and more
interesting things there is a lot of
resurgence at the moment of sort of the
well in one hand you can call them the
Doomsday predictions on the other hand
the singularity people uh of of is do
you believe something like AGI is
imminent something or let's call it
human level AI do you think because then
all these questions pop up of of ethics
of how do we treat machines that display
the same level of intelligence are you
generally in the I want to say that the
group of people who believe yes the
acceleration is so drastic that it's
really imminent we're gonna create
intelligence whatever that means or is
it more the the direction that says well
it's a really good machine but it's
still like a totally a machine I think
this technology is extraordinary and
what we're seeing right now is the
closest thing we've ever seen to general
intelligence uh and I think we're going
to see a lot of progress over the next
few years that pushes the limits even
farther
um so I'm very excited about the
possibility at the same time uh I think
that intelligence is generally a
complicated topic it's difficult to
Define we often simplify it to a
one-dimensional scale like a test score
where one person has a higher score than
another and that means they're smarter
but in the real world I don't believe
that's how it really works intelligence
is so multi-dimensional there's eight
billion people on the planet and
um there are so many different kinds of
talents so many different ways those
talents are expressed
and also it turns out that our value in
this universe is not based on being the
best at anything I'm not the best person
at anything that out of the 8 billion
people on the planet there's always
somebody that's better than me in every
single aspect every single dimension of
my life and yet I'm still able to find
meaning and purpose and uh able to
contribute and I think that that's going
to remain true so I generally don't like
um
boiling everything down into a
one-dimensional scale and start starting
to extrapolate uh what does that mean if
we're all less than something else
because I just don't think that that's
realistic I don't I don't think that's
how uh the world has ever worked
um at the same time you know I do
recognize that there are uh going to be
some challenges uh that this technology
poses because
um every time there's been a new way of
organizing human work it has changed the
ways that we think about ourselves and
about what we do
um and that is disruptive and it could
have the potential to to hurt people so
I think that we need to be cautious
about how we deploy this technology we
need to try to put safeguards around it
honestly I think open AI has been quite
responsible
um they have tried really hard to make
chat GPT safe to use and um and you know
it's not perfect but they they've I
think done a really good job of of
making the technology better I think we
have more to go and then I think we need
to think about you know what are the
implications of deploying this
technology I think that it's true that
um you know some kinds of work are going
to be able to be solved by these models
and so some people are going to find
that you know they have an opportunity
to to use their time uh hopefully in a
different way hopefully in a better way
I think generative AI is necessary in
order to grow our economy as a worldwide
civilization we need tools we need
better tools for intellectual work and
that's what generative AI is is better
tools for understanding the problems
that we we need to solve and then
helping people uh get their work done
more efficiently
and you know just as uh prior industrial
revolutions have changed the the way
that people work I think this one will
is well my grandfather could never have
dreamed of me spending my life working
in AI because you know 70 years ago AI
didn't exist it it just wouldn't have
made any sense to him and I think that
that is the normal progression of human
civilization is that as we grow as we
mature we find new opportunities and you
know the things that we did in the past
uh stay in the past we change you know
it used to be that everyone or almost
everyone was a farmer and these days we
were able to dramatically more
productive per person that's working in
agriculture and that
I think has been a really good thing
because it has opened up possibilities
for us to do some something else and you
know that's what progress looks like
um that's the only way that human
civilization progresses is by improving
itself and becoming more productive and
and AI is what we call the tools for
making intellectual work more productive
so um although I agree that there are
there are challenges and we need to be
thoughtful and careful and we need to
try to take care of people I also
believe that this technology is
foundational to our future
cool beautiful beautiful words we'll
leave it at that Brian thanks so much
for talking to me and uh invite everyone
to come to your your session